from where mark sent this report there
is a degree of safety in numbers on the
road north to the disaster zone we
travel in a convoy because the risk
further ahead of being stopped and
robbed is now high not only other
desperate people willing to steal but
two prisons have been damaged and have
emptied it's been a full day just to get
on the move it's taken hours for the aid
teams to source all the supplies medical
kits food water and fuel and we've got
perhaps ten hours on the road ahead in
the vehicles our doctors as well as
communication specialists from the
French charity telecoms sont francais
air there are plenty of stops to hear
for the a-team to update the military on
their movements it's a chance to catch
up with them briefly it's the first
thing when we hit the ground is to get
in touch with our partners at the center
of the ASEAN bnpb the governments and
see what the priorities are for internet
connections we set up the internet
connections Decker takes us a couple
hours to do that to get them back up and
running and then we send a few teams
around to contact the population and
provide the recruiting operations the
convoy has been organized by local medic
Chandra sin-bearing it's a slow process
yeah because we need to make sure
everything is okay for the security
issue because now we have Duke done
coordination with the army and they have
spread the army in the road from our
side to dongle aah and to balloon no
it's safe now we pass through towns
unaffected the roads here are fine but
landslides on the windy coastal road up
ahead won't help it's the aftermath of
this which the eight teams of us now
deal with it looks almost unbelievable
computer-generated but this was Mother
Nature at the weekend
it's a phenomenon called liquefaction it
happens when saturated soil loses its
stiffness because of the violent tremors
the ground literally turns to liquid
there are now more than 60,000 people
here in Peru without homes food water or
fuel only in the last 24 hours as it
begun slowly to get through the looting
in the town is understandable they need
the food and the water and they all
complain that it's not getting through
for so many though it is too late the
piles of body bags hold some dignity and
a vital - to prevent disease from
spreading mass burials have now taken
place for the hundreds whose bodies have
been recovered but it's feared so many
here already lied deep under the mud
their remains may never be found
mark stone Sky News in Sulawesi
Indonesia